Patrick Ewing the hall of famer and a
Georgetown head coach he will be
representing the Knicks tonight in the
NBA draft lottery as we flash back to
1985 when the Knicks won the lottery and
Dave DeBusschere had that great reaction
and they selected Patrick Ewing and the
Georgetown head coach kind enough to
join us good morning Patrick where are
you today good morning fellas doing and
I'm Washington DC right now in
Washington just relax until I head up to
Chicago for the lottery are you are you
taking an uber you're flying you're
taking the train how you getting there
the Knicks are sending their plane whoa
yeah how did this how did this come up
where the Knicks asked you to represent
them in the lottery I was given a call
by Steve Mills in it as he told me that
mr. Tolin would like for me to do in
this favor and represent the team and I
thought about it I thought it was a
great idea so here I am so what it was
34 years ago yeah two years ago where
were you the night of the lottery 34
years ago I was and coach times his
office on Joyce Townes campus myself
David fall Mary fénelon coach Thompson
we all sit there watching it and when
the when the next one we all jumped up
and and celebrated you wanted to go
there well you know it was my next was
my second choice was Golden State
because sleeping floor was on on that
team and you know it was I had somebody
who he was somebody I play with I was
familiar with and I thought it was it'd
be a great great idea to play with
someone that I do but when they didn't
win it and the Knicks won I did not want
to go to Indiana nothing against Indiana
but I would rather stay closer to home
but the pressure you came in with can
you do remember what that felt like that
you were being asked to revitalize the
franchise
what precise you know is when I first
got here we were terrible
my first two year and my first two years
we were terrible it was nothing that you
know I didn't expect for us to be that
bad
and I'm sure that and the fans didn't
expect for us to be that bad so and they
lashed out I remember one one night I
had a poster night off it was my book
here we had a poster night and I had
been hurt and I came back and played
that game [ __ ] and played but I played
and I can remember them ripping the
poster up on a mother some guy he ripped
my head out of the out of the poster put
his head in there it was it was it was
it was a it was a learning experience
but you know that's sports you know
you're gonna have good night you're
gonna good nice good years good decades
and you're gonna have bad
we started out slow but I thought that
you know we ended great and we didn't
win the championship but we were right
there competing let's put this to bed
right right now I'm Patrick Ewing
joining us what did you know about the
possibility of that 85 lottery being
fixed you know what everyone keeps
bringing that even today they still say
that as I see them I'm sure it's gonna
come up about a thousand times more you
know that it was expected with a cold
envelope and with a bent envelope as tip
was been something that is because these
conspiracy theories but you know what it
might have been suspected I don't care I
ended up where I was supposed to end of
New York needed to have a team a strong
team to you know make the league
stronger and that's what happened how
are you in the the league planning on
fixing it tonight so the next one well
you know I can't tell you okay we love
you we have a great relationship but I
I'm hoping that you know I can repeat
that that magical magical night and the
Knicks are able to come away with the
number one pick and I think it's really
special that Patrick told me this nobody
else knows is he's wearing his old
Knicks uniform tonight at the watering
can you fit into that uniform wouldn't
it be great if Patrick went out there
and is in his full mix uniform rip off
rip off the warm-ups there you got the
kneepads on you're ready to go yeah that
would be great
didn't you talk to me about you couldn't
get into Zions living room like you you
thought about recruiting or tried to and
you didn't have a shot right I tried to
get a sit-down and it didn't happen you
know when I when I heard about him
exactly McDonald's was the one who told
me about him and you know I try to get a
sit-down went to South Carolina try to
see him didn't happen but you know he
played it picked a great school for
himself and it should have been
Georgetown but you know that's how it is
what do you think of the possibility of
ending the one-and-done here in a couple
of years it's gonna happen yeah you know
it's gonna happen you know they've been
talking about it for a couple years I
think is in about two years it's gonna
stick I know they're gonna get rid of it
you know it's you have all these other
sports that you can you know go straight
from high school and in some way you
know at least having having the option
to do it I think it's something good if
Kevin Durant called you and asked for
advice on New York what would you tell
him Tom you know New York is a great
city you know there's no place like it
the fans they their basket they're
knowledgeable at least they think their
knowledge
but I think it would be a great great
situation Utley you know a great be a
great fit no matter where he goes may be
a great fit in New York and the friends
will definitely embrace them
I hope the fans don't get upset if you
if the Knicks don't win the lottery and
then they start booing you again I hope
that doesn't happen Patrick well you
know a part of life and if they boo me
they boo me but I think it was something
great too to be for them for the next to
call and ask me to do this for them and
I'm proud too I'm proud to be a Knick
I'm proud of my experience there in New
York you know like I said it started out
rocky but we ended strong and you know
we are we are our experience and those
were great times for me well safe
travels to Chicago great talking to you
thanks for reaching out the other night
I appreciate that I appreciate that
like I said yo you are in my prayers and
I wish you a speedy recovery Thank You
Patrick that's Patrick Ewing Georgetown
head coach Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
exclusive tired the Dan Patrick show for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]